revenge just once or twice he wants
revenge forever as soon as a player
beats him once and okay the game has
started it's the reti opening magnus
opening uh the game with his knight and
the young kristoff duda pushing a pawn
so very standard stuff actually in later
years this has been my favorite move
with white just bringing the night out
staying flexible not committing the
pawns yet and again magnus not
committing anything in the center just
pushing upon getting ready to fiance to
his bishop onto the long diagonal with
white is that what you played in the two
games that you won against nils uh it
wasn't actually
i shouldn't confess this but in my
matching against neil's granddaddy's i
had no idea what to play and a friend i
won't name him suggested i roll a dice
to choose my first move and i rolled
that it would be 1d4 so i played 1d4
throughout the entire match ah which
took some pressure off the preparation
but uh okay magnus he's also a player
who can play anything he can play lots
of different types of openings and here
we go black bishop coming out yeah i
like this move very much i used to play
that for black so but i think white
still can get um an advantage in this
variation quite easily but black's super
solid right black brings the bishop out
before committing the pawns maybe black
will put all the pawns on the light
squares now that bishop's out on
an active square yeah definitely and
maybe we'll hinge on
where the black knight on the right side
of the board will develop well it's that
on the f line or it's uh perhaps weight
and a step to the square in front of the
king i actually play this as well with
the black pieces so i love it when the
grand masters
follow our openings and we get to learn
a little bit i must admit i'm always a
little bit disappointed when they lose
with the openings that i play but when
they win
a part of me thinks yes
i've got a lesson there and very logical
play uh by both sides so far magnus
there just distracted for a minute
clearly just trying to get into the
groove um he just brought his bishop out
and black as expected is just gonna
build a wall of pawns on the light
squares and yeah it's fascinating i play
this only with the white side so i'm
going to learn from what magnus does
and you two play it from the black side
so i guess we'll see what duda does and
either way the reason i love this
position so much is because
the price of each move is actually a lot
lower than in some mainstream openings
normally in for example open sicilians
where it's really direct you have to
attack otherwise your whole position
falls apart here with white
magnus was thinking for a long time he
could have castled his king he could
push this pawn he could have pushed
other pawns you're super flexible and
there's less pressure at this early
stage the tension tends to arise later
in the middle game ivanka yeah and i was
going to say uh well magnus definitely
increasing the stakes as he pushes a
pawn to challenge in the center and uh
there you saw a little nice little
triangle from black from the light
squares but after pawn takes pawn this
is going to be an interesting moment
because will jan christoph duda actually
play bishop takes knight or will he
actually recapture the pawn and he's
gone for the solid choice and that is to
go bishop takes knight bishop takes
bishop and uh now capture with the sea
pawn yep so we did see a couple of
traits ivanka briefly mentioned the
triangle formation that's actually a
really popular formation for black but
now after a trade of knight for bishop
the pawn structure is going to become
very symmetrical so
technically white should have a small
advantage because white has the bishop
pair black has more knights but white's
bishops have the potential to become
very strong but look at the pawn
structure it's very blocked at the
moment and those white bishops
especially that white bishop that has
just moved it's going to be locked in
behind its own pawns for a while still
so
this position i've even had it myself
and actually until this last move but by
the way it's just solid start from both
sides anastasia i have that i think why
actually black gave up his uh good
bishop let's say on g4 it's the question
maybe which our spectators are asking
yeah that's actually a really good point
maybe if we jump into the position just
to show earlier just if we rewind a few
moves there's a really interesting
moment black has two choices you can
take this way or this way you actually
want to capture towards the center this
point isn't quite in the center you want
to capture towards the center but this
would end up in a nasty check and a
double attack so that's why black parted
with his bishop first he traded off for
the night and then he's erected this
really strong wall of pawns so if we
catch up with the current game position
look at this wall of pawns they're still
here and these pawns are blunting out
white's light squared bishop this light
square bishop is struggling to get into
the game because it's simply staring at
black's stronghold here so
white now has brought the queen out both
sides have occupied this potential open
line with their rooks and if young
christophe duda is solid and patient
then he might be able to trade off all
the rooks on this line later on and then
the position will kind of slowly steer
itself towards a draw but if magnus can
open things up for example later explode
up in the center with some pawns then
maybe the bishop pair will become more
useful than black's knights so it's
really tense it's all about strategy now
it's not about calculation it's not
about any attack look how safe both
kings are right now both kings
i mean they wouldn't face any danger for
the rest of the game but it's all about
small strategic ideas and building up
those tiny advantages for later yeah
it's all about fine-tuning those small
moments as david mentioned and
definitely an exciting game and one
thing that we do want to stress
throughout this uh this charity cup is
that we do want to get excited about the
chess and so we really still want to see
your tweet yeah uh your suggestions uh
your questions and also your selfies and
remember you can do that by tweeting us
using the hashtag chesschamps definitely
there we go young christophe doodle
what's he drinking is that coffee is
that coca-cola or
every different player has a different
uh favorite drink yeah and he's uh very
thirsty but he looks relaxed huh yeah he
does yeah well i'm yeah after you said
that david about you know maybe this
puts pressure off him that he just came
into the tournament very late i'm
excited to see how christoph duda will
do in this tournament he uh he was
knocked out in the preliminaries in the
air things masters
and it's going to be interesting to see
if he can make it through to the
quarterfinals in this one here we go
yeah and actually i'm really surprised
by the pace that both players have
started playing so early in the game
neither player is spending that much
time so far both still with over 14
minutes and
still there's some big decisions being
made magnus there retreating with his
knight he's just opening up um the line
for his rook maybe trying to maneuver
that knight to
a more promising uh circuit later on
still
i mean i personally prefer white's
position but
i'm just surprised that neither players
slowed down to really form a long-term
plan somehow i started to look for some
jumps of this knight from sis from
c c file maybe not like 95 94 but at the
moment the queen is not defended right
on d7 so but it's something in the air
yeah no these are the small moments that
we were talking about those small little
things that black would love to move the
night they can't do that and the white
knight on the other hand can go on a big
jump jumping circuit yeah and anastasia
mentioned this black queen is not
defended
for example you wanted to jump out the
way um hit the white queen maybe also
hit some pieces this was actually
possible because uh now the white queen
is undefended there's tension between
the queens and after quinte's queen
black could have stepped back and
recaptured this would just be a queen
trade um so i think jan christoph duda
he's set up now an idea that you
mentioned he has defended that black
queen and he doesn't want to defend it
with the knight the knight wants to do
maybe uh some damage in white's position
so he's just stepped his rook forward a
dual purpose move firstly always double
up your rooks if you can the two rooks
are going to team up on this open file
and secondly he's defended his queen so
now if white is really careless for
example and pushes this pawn forward
gets aggressive trying to push forward
to destabilize the black knight there
would be tricks such as knight takes
pawn jumping out of the way and this is
your idea anastasia hitting the white
queen but also now after the white queen
takes the black queen you don't need to
recapture you can flick in a check
winning a piece first and then next move
winning uh recapturing the white queen
so magnus of course is not going to fall
for that trap
but a really sneaky idea there from duda
and meanwhile a couple of moves magnus
bringing his king up so now no more
checks from the black knight defending
his loose bishop on this square and
black now jumping forward and the white
knight continuing to jump as well so
both sides have their ideas i really
like this black knight on this square it
can jump in at some point to white half
of the board white's knight wants to do
the same though he wants to dance back
and then forward to attack the black
queen it's just a maneuvering battle but
there's always hidden tactical tricks in
the position and uh that was one of them
and it really seems like center is in
play in this game so many many of the
pieces just you know
cramped up in the center there yeah do
you think the black queen feels
claustrophobic just all of its pieces
around
but yeah this is just good strategy
right just centralize your pieces if in
doubt and uh not too much can go wrong
if everything protects each other as
well
it's just really instructive how white's
king stepped up to defend the white
light squared bishop stopping any
potential checks then the black rook
also stepped up defending the black
queen everything's protected and
still i think that's why the evaluation
bar says 0.1 0.0 is just dead level both
sides just playing very sensible chess
yes they play very well and magnus also
with move king king moving his move uh
his king forward managed to show us one
prophylactical uh move right king
what is that prophylactical move i hear
that sometimes what is that
yeah it's a prophylactic move it's uh
it's such a move which actually stops
all ideas of your opponent and it's
actually a very annoying thing because
like you would like to do something you
know but you cannot because your
opponent understood what are you going
to to play and he
decided to protect against that so you
don't like this kind of moves from your
opponent because it ruins your plan yeah
you have to think of something else
sometimes okay but this one was a very
typical quite easy one more
prophylactical yes
it's instructive for everyone because
when we're young we're just focused
purely on our own plans it's all about
checkmating the king we don't care what
our opponent wants to do
but yeah as we get older we realize okay
this is our opponent's plan we'll stop
it three moves in advance frustrate the
opponent and only then pursue our own
plans and as
anastasia says it's super frustrating
when you come up with this really genius
idea and your opponent stops it before
it's even
close to being on the board
it's even been said that some of the top
players are so good they will stop your
plan before you've even thought about it
some famous world champions like the
trojan who was famous for doing this
yeah it's just impossible to have fun
against these players because they stop
you having fun before
the fun becomes an idea and wow
yeah look at this move aggression now
from christoph duda pushing upon hitting
the white queen and ivanka i'm trying to
work this out is that a sacrifice can
white just grab that pawn it's
undefended and a big question now for
magnus carlsen if he has to run away
with the white queen then dude's move
has been justified but if you can take
this pawn safely
yeah the proof is in the pudding right
we have to bring up the board and check
out why white can't just capture that
pawn and uh queen takes pawn
queen takes pawn it looks like a free
pawn i guess the idea is that black's
rook wants to slide across to hit the
white queen and now when the white queen
sidesteps i'm guessing she returns back
where she came from or similar square
then now black can capture this pawn and
because he's opened up a line for his
rook this knight is now defended so this
would just result in a series of trades
for example capture here and a capture
here and
level number of pawns again
i'm still not sure who to favor to be
honest i quite like this black rook
eyeing up the white king indirectly but
then again it does feel a bit loose for
black this knight has some pressure on
it from the white rook from the white
queen either way if we backtrack in the
current position this pawn push pushing
the b pawn forward hitting the white
queen from duda the fact that he played
it so quickly and so confidently means
that he's calculated this out and he's
pretty confident that if as mentioned
queen takes pawn the rook can just slide
across and black is doing okay that
being said the evaluation bar does not
like what duda has done so magnus he is
trying to make him prove it he has
captured this pawn this is the current
position the white queen under attack
from the black rook queen stepping back
and uh now will duda recapture this pawn
or does he have something even more
sneaky up his sleeve i think he just has
to take this pawn i think so too yeah he
has to hope that his position just holds
together for the next few moves the
evaluation bar meanwhile correcting
itself maybe seeing that black's idea is
just about okay risky but it's okay
we like risky yeah we like risk we do
like risk but on the other hand i wasn't
like david i wasn't entirely convinced
by the resulting position and this is
often something that we say when we when
you finish your calculations take a deep
breath stop
and evaluate that exactly evaluate the
position that you have and uh you know
you've kind of been there you've seen
everything up close now you need to sit
there take a step backwards and just see
whether the action is good for you
because over here i'm not entirely sure
because
magnus has retreated his knight in order
to attack the rook but look at the
knight the knight can actually jump to a
dark square it has a nice post there the
light square bishop that is sitting next
to the king on the right doesn't quite
look like it's doing anything looking at
a wall but if we think ahead uh it can
mobilize itself and do some crafty
maneuverings and it will be start
looking at that the night on the light
squares on c6 square um i don't know i'm
thinking that white still has what we
call in chess a nibble
a tiny little advantage
a little
thing to bite on yeah
it's the type of advantage that it's not
big so we don't really want to talk
about it but we have to give it a name
i like it yeah you chew away your
opponent's position until something
cracks all right um and yeah right now
it's the type of advantage that it's
temporary because if magnus can jump in
with his knight if at the moment he's
attacking the black rook if he could do
something over the next three or four
moves he will have an advantage but if
duda defends well
it could just fizzle out pieces could be
traded and it's also opposite color
bishops so if the queens and rooks
disappear the knights disappear it's
just going to be a draw so duda has to
be accurate but
it's within the realms of a defendable
position right now
who do you prefer
yeah i think white is doing well but
actually at the beginning i thought it's
it's so nice to have the rook on the
second row this is what we used to know
that if you manage to bring your rook to
the second row to the seventh rank
it's good for you but unfortunately for
this rook i don't think it's
that black should really keep it
there yes on the second rank because you
can even maybe lose this rook i mean it
will it looks scary right example if you
try to attack this knight right with
putin the rook on d2 then i don't know
i'm not sure maybe this rook will not
manage to get out uh so i don't know
probably we can simply get stuck
basically yes it can get trapped you
know look how lonely this rook feels i
mean all of black's army are the other
half of the board so far away and this
rook as you mentioned might get trapped
the queen will just step back and maybe
step across and try and win it so okay
the rook was not brave enough to stay on
this ideal second rank it has indeed
stepped back where it came from and uh
magnus has one move to try and cause
some damage
ivanka you mentioned trying to get this
bishop back i like that idea as well
ideally you want to kind of step it back
and then jump over your own knight and
start pinning
the enemy pieces but at the moment it's
hard to get this piece into the action
we could see a scenario maybe where
white tries to get this rook which is
doing nothing in the corner into the
game but if you slide it across it just
gets traded off for black's rook uh
maybe you could try and step up your
rook at some point uh up to this square
or this square and then double up but
yeah it's uh small small nibbles here
it's not a huge advantage and magnus if
he can get one of these two pieces into
the game he'll be very happy but duda is
rock solid everything defended uh
everything protecting each other right
now yeah
definitely i
it's very small isn't it it's very small
things than like you say could equally
fizzle out if magnus were feeling super
enterprising while we still have the
board up i mean but it takes incredible
risk you can actually push the pawn
forward in the center yeah and
bulldoze open that line however it is
incredibly risky and you have to have a
real good feel for the dynamics to even
think about making a move like that
because you can't undo pawn moves and it
will create a big weakness yeah and for
example after it portrayed in the center
there white has an isolated pawn and
yeah could definitely backfire so yeah
if we look at the pawn structure right
now it's almost completely symmetrical
that's why we would be thinking of moves
such as breaking forward in the center
trying to create some action
symmetrical pawn structures very rarely
give either side a big advantage well
magnus carlsen is definitely thinking
about the next move will he take that
risk we do have the first result in the
charity cup eric hanson and hans niemann
have played a draw in their first game
so a long break for them before game two
we also see richard report the bar all
the way over to his side against juwon
june and looking good also for liam lee
against lighting g
and
actually that's a really interesting
battle uh hands against hanson
[Laughter]
hanson against niemann there and uh i
just took a look over at that game and
actually last week in my match against
nils grendelius i was doing some opening
preparation i had studied the exact
position that they finished on
in that game so a battle in the italian
game it was a battle of kind of memory
work
and clearly both sides had studied it
very deeply so i draw a fair result
interesting
and uh well everyone look at david he's
wearing his beautiful chest high and
this tie is now being put up for auction
as a fundraiser for unicef and you can
make a bid
for that fantastic chest high so kind of
you david put it up for auction and it's
on cct auction.com
and this auction will finish today so
you only have a few hours to put in your
bid and if you go into that site you can
also see a bunch of other stuff that is
put up for auction for the charity cup
some very cool pieces on there
and i think i've actually worn this tie
for most of the final days uh throughout
last season's uh champions chess tour so
yeah it's gonna be emotional but uh
either way yeah i hope it does go to a
good home yes and obviously for a good
goal so please please donate yes is it a
lucky tie david oh good question
um actually i was telling kai just
before the show i used to be famous for
wearing a checkered wristband on my
wrist i think for more than 10 years 10
15 years
every tournament every chess game i
played i had to wear a checkered
wristband and a group of kids would
follow me around they would call them
howlers and they would wear the
wristband as well but then one
tournament i just forgot to bring it i
didn't pack it and
then i decided okay i needed something
else that's checkered and while i was
abroad i went to a shop and i found this
tie so
it was just a replacement as uh as kind
of a secondary lucky charm and
i can't complain it brought me some luck
it brought me here to oslo exactly and
uh okay meanwhile a move
uh by magnus carson he has jumped in
with his knight and i think one of you
mentioned this right so attacking the
black queen but this knight can get
traded off for the black bishop and
there we go the knight eliminated it was
just too strong on that outpost had to
be traded and now magnus recapturing
with this rook he's created a path for
that rook in the corner to get into the
game so we might well see magnus try and
stack up his rooks
and still some pressure um i'm not sure
i'd like the white bishop here compared
to the black knight but there are some
immediate threats i thought about this
bishop and knight competition here
who is better who is worse which do you
normally prefer
i don't know i mean i look at this
bishop i don't like it but if it starts
moving
yes but still the pieces of white are
quite active right at this moment this
rook i mean he can also take the c file
so
and the pawns on both sides of the board
so bishops do have some potential i mean
well there were a couple of moves
black's knight ran out of the way from
some potential attacks and the queens
got traded so we're in the end game now
and uh magnus
doing magnus things every game i see him
play he pushes his a pawn forward two
squares and this is actually again
something that nils grandelisk did
against me every game we played when he
had white his pawn flew up the board it
must be from his work with magnus and
yeah this a pawn push doesn't really do
too much but it just looks like it's
slowly inching towards its promotion
square and the rook's back to where you
wanted it anastasia the second rank
interesting play both rooks getting
active
and uh okay pawn structure is still
symmetrical it's going to be hard for
magnus to try and create
something tangible but then again it's
possible there's still enough material
left and enough imbalance now with the
bishop versus knight
to try and create winning chances
now age four
simon's favorite move
it can never be a bad move his house and
it's a good life philosophy yeah 90 and
it must be nice i mean so many times
when i'm playing chess i'm just wha what
should i do and the clock's taking and i
just have no idea it must be so nice to
always have that move to go to yeah
yeah
most of the time i understand you know
it's the time yeah i have to say that i
mean it's a good luxury move yeah or if
you're feeling really really aggressive
and your opponent has uh developed put
his pawns in one particular way then you
can feel entitled to push that age pawn
and and here it's a nice move just to
kind of say hey i'm potentially going to
expand on the right side of the board
push up the fellow g pawn maybe even an
f-born once the king steps out of the
rook's eye line um in the meantime
black needs to think also about
just activating the knight and
activating the king because he would
love to move the knight and move it to
the f5 square unfortunately there is
something called a back rank mate in the
air and that knight is tied down to the
defense of the bottom row
yeah if the knight moves then as yivanka
mentions the route will come up and this
king is trapped uh no way out that would
end in checkmate so that's why black
gives his king some breathing space and
now there's a safe square so we call
this luft which just means ah
giving the king square and magnus wow
okay magnus pushing forward and yankers
of duda
i'm shocked by this he's pushed his pawn
forward again another pawn sacrifice we
saw earlier in the middle game with
another pawn on the other side of the
board now he's given up a pawn here but
his whole idea is that after the pawn
recaptures i think he's just going to
jump forward with the black knight and
now he's actually eyeing up two pawns so
white's a pawn up temporarily but black
is trying to hit this pawn with a check
but also hitting this pawn with a check
because this pawn in the center is not
actually guarded by its fellow here
which is pinned along the second rank so
for example after pawn takes pawn young
christoph has a choice but he could just
play knight takes pawn with a check and
after the king moves he could drop back
and recapture and he's just trying to
eliminate everything on this right side
of the board magnus says i'm i believe
you i'm not having any of that and uh
okay he has just ignored this bringing
his rook across instead so uh duda
successfully being able to trade a set
of pawns yeah but a nice move for h5
actually
really cool fighting for space as well
um this to be honest would not have been
on my radar that's why someone like duda
is so
so special so talented and one of the
best players in the world yeah yeah
now i'm impressed by that move but i
also would like to add a little word of
caution here because you know it's
sometimes recklessly pushing pawns
forward and in games i mean you really
do have to consider where whether they
will be a weakness in the long term or
an asset because uh say for instance
white is allowed to capture the pawns
then maybe that porn is a weakness and
this is why you see duda exchange pawns
and uh well the big question is whether
why it's porn on age
four will become a strength or will it
become a weakness
yeah magnus might well try and push it
forward just to trade it off at some
point because it is isolated and i know
we joke about harry and uh often harry
ends up winning games by kind of using
itself as a battering ram or pushing
through in the end game but here it is
uh it is isolated and it's unlikely to
be able to push further without getting
traded to be honest i don't see any
danger for duda for example if he just
waits uh maybe there are more productive
moves but even if he just brings his
king up one square to a dart square away
from any checks uh for example magnus he
might try and infiltrate on the seventh
rank trying to break through this is
where rooks love to be as anastasia
mentioned the second round for
blackrocks the counterpart is the
seventh for white so but after not
trading um because this would allow an
attack and a double attack um after
black's rook instead maybe just drops
back covers the seventh rank we would
just see a trade of one set of rooks
white's rook has to decide he has to
capture one of the black brooks and for
example now black just maintains full
control that just doesn't have any
weaknesses that's magnus's problem this
rook now defends everything defends this
side of the board the king defends all
of these pawns they defend each other
and
yeah there we go the king has moved no
real worries for duda actually it's a
perfect position you described when
everybody defends each other yes like
chess pieces they're like a team and if
they defend each other you cannot miss
something you cannot lose hang in peace
so it's a good idea to to protect
your pieces by using all of them
yeah yeah so exactly no weaknesses no
weaknesses so for example yeah if the
rook comes up just defend everything
bring your rook back and uh things will
get traded off and this is the type of
chess i play these days old manchester
defend everything and just wait for your
opportunity wait for your opponent to
get impatient and magnus okay he doesn't
want to see the rooks leave the board he
wants to keep as many pieces on for
later so he pushes forward and when in
doubt push pawns on the flanks that was
what we've learned so far but you know i
have a feeling that magnus has a very
sneaky plan and it's to do with pushing
uh annie alice alice how can i forget
the name
all the way to the sixth square and
david's highlighting it and then and
only then to move forward with the rook
to the seventh row okay he's done it in
one go he's moving the rook to the
seventh row seventh heaven
i guess ivanka unfortunately this pawn i
mean it would love to step forward with
this idea of marching forward with the
rook but
i like that
yeah unfortunately right now it's not
possible because the rook would just
gobble up this pawn there's actually no
way of defending this pawn anymore
safely for white you'd love to retreat
your bishop for example bring it back to
defend this pawn but remember this rook
has its eyes on two sides of the wood
and this bishop would be undefended so
uh okay magnus instantly bringing his
rook up to challenge the black rook yeah
but still black has got some questions
to answer and it's all gonna be along
the seventh row because uh if you do sit
tight and try to hold that seventh row
then your rook might be out of squares
and the light square bishop can
show her long range possibility and
david's probably gonna highlight the
diagonal she wants to go to this one yes
and over this side later but meanwhile
okay duder has just traded a set of
rooks and this is really clever he's
brought his rook across i think we're
going to see a result soon because he's
hitting this pawn and if white goes and
grabs this black born the knight is just
going to come to the side
attacking the rook attacking this pawn
and when the rook moves we would just
see everything getting traded off the
whole left side of the board has
disappeared all of the pawns getting
traded and
once that happens
if players only on one side of the board
it's bound to be a draw just no
imbalances really yeah actually pay
attention it was another prophylactical
move by duda in this game when he moved
his king uh towards the center he
actually defended against the idea
bishop uh take the pawn
so maybe
let's say it's it's it's another
prophylactical move in this game
yeah for example um in if as expected
rook takes pawn happens the knight moves
say the rook moves after knight takes
pawn if the king was back on the seventh
rank due to this pin white could win a
pawn but really clever play from duda
there he's just eliminating everything
and look at magnus's body language let's
go back to the players because he is not
happy he knows he's been neutralized
duda very calm very relaxed defending
this game really well white's remaining
porn alice is just about to drop off and
he's going to end the draw yeah
and i guess uh young christophe duda
will be happy with that result against
world champion magnus carlsen remember
it could be these two that we see in the
next world championship match young
christoph duda is ready to play in the
candidates and well anastasia you've
been a commentator you've been leading
the press conferences at so many world
championship matches how many has it
been i'm trying to remember because i've
been also two women's well the
championships too uh so i think three um
world championships and probably like
two or three four women
really lost the track and uh yeah i mean
we could we could see duda next time
yeah it's really possible i mean he's
one of the participants in the
candidates tournament um and also kaya
we were meeting we were together in
sochi i mean
for the world championship when magnus
played against
vishan ant i remember you were playing
chess 2 at that time so how do you feel
you're learning you're learning yes i
haven't gotten much better either but i
am learning sitting in the studio here
this is what i wanted to ask you how is
it going
to have to check
i can promise you most of our viewers
would still beat me if playing online
against me i'm i'm just not very patient
but i am trying to learn and i'm getting
very good at capturing center in the
start of the games at least yeah yeah i
think it's stuff yeah it's a good start
all right we have another move but uh
still heading towards that draw i
suppose david yeah magnus still trying
to set some small um problems for duda
to solve um we saw that white pawn did
indeed disappear but after the black
knight went to capture it white's rook
has gone back to where it came from and
this is what we call a pin that black
knight cannot move out the way because
then the black rook would drop behind it
so magnus just causing some discomfort
duda at some point will maybe move his
rook to a square it could be protected
by the black knight later for example if
the black rook steps up the board at
this point or in the next few moves one
square and then the black knight can
move and just defend its own rook so you
can break the pin it's not a type of
eternal pin that we sometimes see in
games that do decide results um duda
here yeah he just needs to find the
right square for the black rook there's
not that much choice either the black
king can't move the black knight can't
move so you have to move the black berk
nice move he found the way how to get
out from the spin yeah
there is still one tiny problem left on
the board but i don't think it's a very
difficult challenge you know there's
harry still left and it can advance
forward
and push itself and after all if that
bishop and the rook managed to
coordinate together to attack those okay
it's on the board one final trap yep if
pawn takes pawn this pawn looks a bit
scary only three squares away from
promotion if pawn takes pawn then the
bishop recaptures and
i'm still not sure it's going to decide
the game but at least white will win a
pawn on the next move this pawn is
attacked by the rook and by the bishop
so i'm expecting duda here to just play
it safe and bring his knight out of the
pin and the reason he put his rook on
this square is because the knight now
defends this rook and white
unfortunately doesn't have time to push
this pawn through because his rook is
under fire and duda does indeed play
this if the rooks come off
for example rook takes rook this is just
a dead draw white pawn okay the rooks
have come off white's pawn is not going
to uh break through and become a queen
because even if it does push forward for
example the knight retreats and pushes
forward again the black king can just
step back and easily stop this pawn uh i
think magnus here he's going to accept
the fact it's just a draw and he's going
to play pawn takes pawn and look at the
structure here
complete symmetry three pawns here for
white and three pawns here for black
it's just to draw bishop and knight here
they're just completely balanced all
right so this will probably be a draw by
richard report he's gotten a great start
to his champions chess tour career his
very first tournament in the tour it's a
win for him against jew engine and three
points for richard report
and i always wondered anastasia during
this world championship matches when
you're running these press conferences
how hard is it when a player and maybe
especially magnus has lost the game
okay it's always hard i mean especially
when somebody loses the game somebody
wins i mean the mood is not so great
of the one who just lost the game and
yeah i mean i'm trying to be
you know first of all
a person who understand first of all i'm
a chess player myself so i can i can
understand what players feel at this
moment and i'm not pushing them too much
you know if i have chance to speak with
them if they don't
run away from the press conference so
i'm trying to be nice uh but of course i
mean it's everybody understands what's
happening at this moment and um
yeah i mean i remember those those
situations with vishan and in chennai it
was really hard
to handle the press conference and to
you know also it was very hard for the
players as well i mean
there were sometimes very tricky
questions from other journalists and
so
so on you can imagine i mean
david uh your uncles also i mean all of
us we know how what does it feel to lose
the game i don't know if somebody would
come at this moment and ask me a
question i don't know what i would
answer exactly
very angry well i you know i've been
there myself magnus carl and monsie just
logged off the interview um after losing
a game here in the champions chess tour
as well it can be a little bit difficult
i think we've got 11 words out of him
before
my opponent played very well
goodbye yeah my opponent played very
good goodbye yeah that's what he said so
it can be hard but uh it did something
about chess losing in chess
yeah also
how do you lose your also you know it's
like it's all about it yes if it was a
really nice game let's say at the end
something let's say happened after long
fight it's one story if you blundered
something it's another story so it's
like it's so tricky always you try to
find the right words but it's hard to
find the right words for someone who
really lost right now so i mean okay
it's just part of our job i guess to
handle the situation and try not to
make uh suffering even more
as much as we can yeah i saw a really
interesting uh interview with grishok
and his opponent i can't quite remember
who it was and he was asked how long
does it take for him to recover from a
loss and his answer was one hour
which really it was clear it was yeah it
was very time specific but i think yeah
one hour is about right yes at least how
much time it takes for you david to
recover
until my next game i think uh
yeah i'm i'm a bad loser i've got to
admit
i actually played mini golf yesterday
and oh my god i was furious
okay meanwhile a trade of uh pawns and
though you can see on both players body
language
neither of them has big winning chances
here the white bishop stepped back i'm
slightly surprised the black knight
didn't try and recentralize itself maybe
jump in and back
hang in a second the night the night now
is actually trapped in a way it can jump
back
uh at the right moment protected by a
pawn but what do we call the slavanka
simon williams had a name for this the
knight stable the night's stable that's
right keeping that black knight in it
stable not allowed to jump back out this
is a really common pattern when a bishop
or a pawn is kind of two there's two
squares in between and there's a knight
the knight is often dominated but
here i don't think it's enough
um yeah maybe you could bring the black
knight back right now
and there we go and i think a trade here
white capturing that black knight might
even backfire on white if he's not
careful uh black would then just get a
past porn and use that as a distraction
so well calculated by duda and the black
knight now can jump back to safety and
no more domination of the black knight
it's just going to be a draw it's a
matter of time can you remind me please
the rules i mean can you offer a draw
during the game or you have to do the
repetition or what is the rule yeah the
players can't offer a draw i think it's
before move 30 and very rarely do we see
a draw offer actually normally the
players play it out or a drawn position
like this often they'll find a way to
repeat moves
and uh or just exchange everything off
the board and here we go yeah bishop
against king black even sacrificed
tonight but bishop alone cannot deliver
checkmate it's a draw it's a draw all
right